buenas tardes soy francisco y me gusta
escribir
y suelo decir así me gusta escribir
nunca digo soy escritor porque si digo
eso nadie quiere ser mi amigo está un
tema de vida y desde hace muchos muchos
años me dispuesto a escribir
semanalmente puntualmente un artículo en
mi blog y les quiero platicar de un
artículo en concreto porque hace un poco
más de dos años publiqué un artículo
escribí porque un artículo que se
llamaba querido millennial despierta si
lo busca seguramente lo encuentran y
este artículo pues superó todas mis
expectativas en términos de personas y
de alcance y de finalización porque lo
escribí lo publique
luego desapareció un par de días y
cuando regrese y abrí mi artículo lo que
haya pase lo que pasó pero insisto toda
mi imaginación porque llevaba en ese
momento dos millones de views dos
millones de lectores en los próximos
días el número fue subiendo fueron
cuatro luego seis cuando deje de contar
más o menos a las dos semanas y valen
diez millones de lectores que para un
millennial que escribe es un éxito pues
renombrado 10 millones por fin un
artículo viral por fin el mundo me da lo
que merezco
lo que no saben es que el mundo medio es
exactamente lo que merezco porque el
problema de ese artículo o lo
interesante de ese artículo no era el
artículo sino los comentarios del
artículo
porque vi 10 millones de views ok y
luego
4000 comentarios y entonces dije ok
venga y empecé a leer
los comentarios por ser muy discreto y
muy leve no fueron buenos en su mayoría
fueron comentarios muy malos muy
agresivos muy críticos como estamos
acostumbrados a dar y a recibir durante
unos pocos días en aquel invierno de
2016 me sentí el hombre más odiado del
mundo obviamente no lo era pero sí me
sentía y cómo nos sentimos nuestros
problemas siempre para nosotros son muy
importantes para el mundo no para el
universo no mi artículo a nadie le
importa realmente pero en ese momento yo
me sentía así porque un comentario y
otro comentario y otro comentario
empezaron a llegar más o menos por estos
términos qué estúpido está tu artículo
primer comentario
ok
muy bien este respira profundo no como
dice chávez lo cuenta hasta 10 segundo
comentario hasta por imbécil muy bien
ok vamos llevando tranquilo cómo va la
cosa tercer comentario que ardido hasta
este hombre es la opinión más desatinada
eres un cerdo marrano que nunca hace
ejercicio
como lo son
impresionante pero bueno así como estos
miles y los que les puse aquí son los
que tienen un lenguaje apropiado para
este horario familiar porque había otros
mucho peores y no menciones a es que
francisco eres
francisco ve
francisco sabes que tú y tú puedes
pero
claro a dos años después igual que
ustedes a mí me da risa desde luego pero
en ese momento no me dio ninguna risa
porque cuando te dicen primera vez
francisco eres
en ese momento estás enojado o te dicen
francisco
diez veces estás agotado pero cuando te
dicen mil veces francisco eres
lo que sucede es que te empiezas a
querer
y algo pasa dentro de ti en esos días
iniciales de la debacle de la
viralización me sentía deprimido
desesperado enojado y me obsesioné por
dos días y dos noches en donde no dormí
y no comí en contestar cada uno de estos
amables comentarios y por supuesto la
reacción natural puede responder fuego
con fuego
francisco eras un pool sabes que tú
terminas
pues tú eres más
de manera que poco a poco se fue
haciendo más grande y más grande y más
grande porque yo pensaba que al hablar
así al contestar así a responder
violencia con violencia fuego con fuego
odio con odio iba a solucionar la
situación pero que creen obviamente cada
contestación que yo daba no mejoraba la
situación solamente le empeoraba no sólo
para ellos sino también para mí y eso
esos días fueron para mí un abismo
oscuro un vórtice que me fue jalando y
jalando y jalando y me sentía deprimido
triste y no sabía qué hacer realmente yo
no sabía qué hacer obviamente nunca
había tenido esa respuesta y pues no
supe cómo controlarlo no supe cómo
manejarlo me faltó madurez me fuerte
inteligencia emocional y estaba
totalmente dominado y en el suelo por un
montón de comentarios de gente que ni
conocía
por supuesto la cosa se puso tan grave
que mi esposa que es muy sabia fue y me
hallo de las greñas no me sacó del hoyo
en que estaba me dijo francisco
o sea qué estás haciendo
está seguro que lo que está haciendo lo
correcto no puedes hacer otra cosa no te
estás metiendo en un problema más grave
yo estoy seguro que tú puedes hacer algo
yo bueno pero qué pero mi esposa me dijo
sabiamente no sé tú
y muy bien lo medité lo pensé otra noche
más sin dormir
y lo irónico de este asunto es que no
todos los comentarios eran malos había
muchos comentarios muy buenos por
ejemplo este si yo hubiese sabido esta
información no estaría donde estoy qué
gran texto lo voy a guardar como tesoro
a algunas personas les pareció
interesante eso me dejaste pensando
frank me hiciste reir muy cierto todo lo
mejor que he leído eres la onda
quizás haciendo un conteo noynoy no hice
un conteo preciso de ambos lados pero yo
creo que más o menos se podían balancear
las cosas y sin embargo como muchas
veces hacemos cuando me pasó eso a mí a
veces elegimos taparnos el ojo de las
cosas buenas que tenemos la cantidad de
bendiciones y oportunidades y amigos de
familia de amor es todo lo que tenemos
bueno nos gusta taparnos el ojo y el ojo
de las cosas malas ponerle binoculares
que amplifiquen la cosa y aunque éstos
me estaban llegando al mismo tiempo en
ese momento no estaban causando ningún
impacto en mí yo solamente estaba
leyendo los comentarios malos
y yo sé que todos hacemos eso
constantemente y poco a poco nos vamos
convirtiendo en una persona que no nos
gusta nosotros mismos
qué pasó qué es lo que decidí después de
esa noche en vela y del consejo de mi
esposa y yo que voy a hacer otra cosa
voy a hacer otra cosa distinta y
entonces al día siguiente día número 36
millones de visitas empecé a contestar
me senté pedir permiso en mi trabajo
literal no casi está previso enfermedad
algo con mi jefe hoy empieza esto
necesito aprenderlo y mi jefe que es a
tomar en ok
y entonces me senté y empecé a contestar
francisco era eso yo contestaba
gracias por leer gracias por compartir
gracias por comentar
eres esto gracias y gracias y gracias y
gracias de miles de gracias durante todo
ese día y el día siguiente y el día
siguiente porque me sentí con la
responsabilidad de contestar a todos y
de agradecerles lo que empezó a suceder
cuando empecé a decir gracias cuando
cambie la respuesta fue mágico en muchos
sentidos primero fue mágico hacia
adentro porque yo mismo empecé a cambiar
los primeros 200 o 300 gracias que dije
pues no los sentía para nada yo quería
mentar madres pero me aguanté opté
decidí decir gracias
y los primeros 300 no me sentía muy bien
pero luego me empecé a sentir mejor y
luego me empecé a sentir pues hasta
contento alegre divertido y no solo
diciendo en los de afuera los otros los
que me estaban ofendiendo los que me
estaban matando la madre también
empezaron a cambiar porque el que me
ofendió le dije gracias y la inmensa
mayoría yo les diría el 99 por ciento de
los ofensores cambiaron por completo la
forma en que se dijeron a mí la mayoría
inmediatamente me pidieron perdón taco
perdóname no sabía no sabía que había
alguien a diestras perdón al menos quise
decir lo obviamente este y matizaron sus
comentarios a partir de ese gracias se
abrieron discusiones más amables
diálogos incluso yo diría amistades hubo
gente que conocí después y que hoy es
amiga mía después de que abrimos
conversación a partir de ese artículo
que sí me cambió la vida
porque me obligó a pensar en las cosas
que uno puede hacer para responder al
input que le llega del mundo exterior
todos todos tenemos muchas cosas que nos
pasan todos los días cosas buenas cosas
malas pero seguramente cosas malas
chiquitas y grandotas la realidad es que
por alguna razón los seres humanos somos
menos expertos en trabajar con las
chiquitas
nos hacemos miserables despreciables
depresivos por las cosas chiquitas se te
cruzó alguien en la calle hoy ya no
puede ser se metió alguien en la fila le
mentaron la madre en redes sociales
cosas pequeñas que objetivamente no
tienen importancia sin embargo nos hacen
verdaderamente perder la cabeza y dejar
de ser quien somos la gente no es
infeliz porque se murió su mamá
o porque hubo una gran tragedia la gente
es infeliz porque no sabe trabajar estos
pequeños vasos de agua en los que nos
gusta constantemente odiarnos la
realidad es que nuestra felicidad en
conjunto depende muy poquito
concretamente un 25 por ciento de las
cosas que nos dan que no decidimos por
ejemplo tú donde naciste cómo te llamas
cómo te apellidas eres actores chaparro
son cosas que te tocan es la lotería que
te tocó pues puede ser buena puede ser
mala lo que tú quieras y eso por
supuesto afecta tu felicidad pero en un
porcentaje muy pequeño tu felicidad
depende realmente en las decisiones en
la actitud que tomas ante las
circunstancias que te han sido puestas
puedes perder toda la vida como yo sin
sintiéndote lástima a ti mismo
contestando violencia con violencia
quejándote del universo y sin hacer nada
al respecto
porque hay quien ha dicho y yo he
escuchado que los sentimientos o
sentirnos bien es una decisión yo creo
que eso es una mentira nosotros no
podemos cambiar nuestros sentimientos
voluntariamente no vamos no se puede así
no funcionan los sentimientos si tú
ahorita que estás aquí pues atento
espero contento a ganar te digo tú
sientes enojada ya 123 ya lo intentará
sentirse enojada por pura voluntad
probablemente no lo va a lograr porque
así no funcionan los sentimientos y
viceversa la gente que está triste o
enojada no podemos ir y decirles cómo a
veces decimos muy optimista mente o
estás triste bueno feliz
la gente está deprimida tiene depresión
clínica tiene problemas verdaderos no te
preocupes tú siéntate bien los
sentimientos no funcionan así y no
podemos hacer nada al respecto los
sentimientos son reacciones de nuestro
cuerpo al tiempo que tenemos las cosas
que nos llegan y nos sentimos hambre con
nuestro cuerpo no está diciendo cómo
sentimos sueño nuestro cuerpo nos dice
bueno
y nos sentimos tristes enojados o
felices en virtud de lo que nos llega
desde afuera y no podemos decidir y la
felicidad no es un adicional en ese
sentido lo que sí podemos hacer es mucho
más interesante podemos tener una
actitud que nos ayude a actuar para
cambiar la situación y ponernos felices
es decir estás triste no te puedes poner
feliz lo que sí puedes es decidir salir
a caminar o puedes decidir salir con tus
amigos
o puedes decidir hacer algo es decir
cambiar el input externo para que tu
cuerpo reaccione y puedas sentirte mejor
cuando tú cambias tu reacción cambias tu
sentimiento y cuando cambias tu
sentimiento cambias tu vida y cambia las
de los demás lo que aprendí en esa
ocasión es una experiencia que a mí no
se me olvida y a partir de ahora me he
propuesto a tomar decisiones nuestra
felicidad es la suma de esas pequeñas
decisiones que todos los días tenemos
que tomar chiquitas pequeñitas como
sentirse como desayunar decir hola no
decir hola contestar no contestar hacer
esa llamada manda
corre o simplemente son acciones y
actitudes lo que nos mantiene pegados a
los sentimientos las personas que no
toman esos sentimientos pero aunque no
toman esas decisiones y que
sencillamente se dejan llevar por el
sentimiento y justificar con sus
sentimientos cualquier cosa porque
existe tal cosa estaba triste no no
ok porque no es un animal tú eras un ser
humano tiene una potestad de decidir y
esa potestad se llama libertad
es lo que nos diferencia de los animales
y es lo que constantemente olvidamos
porque estamos simplemente reaccionando
para mí esos tres días fueron
deprimentes y luego iluminadores y lo
siento decir tres cosas tres cosas
primero todos los días a todas horas a
cada hora del día tienes decisiones que
tomar decisiones muy pequeñas son
decisiones que no las puede tomar nadie
más que tú sobre las cosas que te van
pasando todos los días
chicas y grandes porque como contestas a
una ofensa oa quién eliges con quién
casarte son decisiones que igual van a
tener un impacto al mediano y largo
plazo decídete a tomar esas decisiones
porque son la materia con la que se crea
tu propia felicidad segundo y hablando
de redes sociales y ni siquiera voy a
hacer el intento de decir levanten la
mano que tengan redes sociales porque si
no todos tienen refieres y vivimos en un
mundo en que la mayoría numéricamente
hablando de nuestras relaciones sociales
son digitales son virtuales estamos en
comunidades conectados y tiene
muchísimas ventajas porque tiene sus
riesgos yo les quiero decir dos cosas si
estás de este lado
y tú sientes que te agreden que te dan
like y que no tienen like date cuenta
que hay miles de personas que en todo el
mundo
realmente miren su valor personal por la
manera en que se desarrollan y realmente
gente que se deprime cuando sus fotos
tienen poquitos likes o cuando reciben
comentarios de una u otra manera por
favor tú cambia ese retórica en tu
propia vida tu storytelling cambiarlo
porque tienes que aprender a valorar a
entender lo que son las redes sociales y
lo que no son yo les voy a decir que no
son no son la realidad después de que
recibí 10000 mentadas de madre y me
sentía el hombre más miserable y odiado
y triste del mundo y nadie me quiere y
me tiraba a llorar
saben quién si me seguía queriendo mi
mamá
mi esposa mis hijos mis amigos ya la
gente que importa medianamente no cambió
en absoluto su opinión de mí por esto o
aquello en mi vida real con la gente
real que participaba todos los días me
seguían queriendo igual porque seguía
yendo mal igual pero el caso es que no
cambio esas cosas porque las redes
sociales son esos solamente son
virtuales ahí están son una herramienta
de comunicación de mercadotecnia de
trabajo de venta de lo que quieras pero
no son tu vida y eso sino si se nos
olvida y yo cada vez lo veo más
entienden en personas niños y niñas
pequeños que se meten muy jóvenes y que
no tienen capacidad inteligencia
emocional todavía para lidiar con esta
realidad pero si estás del otro lado ten
mucho más cuidado
porque todos hemos comentado
pues post de otras personas a veces
burlándonos comentando aumentando
bromita jajaja ten mucho cuidado dicen
que las palabras se las lleva el viento
pero no es cierto las palabras tienen
peso tienen sustancia son como rocas y
si tú lanzas
palabras a otras personas causas un
efecto en la vida real
bienvenidos al mundo en donde el 82% de
suicidios entre adolescentes tienen un
componente de redes sociales la gente se
suicida por estas cosas pierde el
sentido de la existencia pierde las
ganas de vivir y yo no quiero nunca que
tu palabra sea la palabra que empuje a
una persona al abismo que empuje a una
persona logra oscuro que empuje a una
persona ponerse una pistola en la boca
no seas tú el asesino si creen que
exagero les puedo asegurar que no es así
es la realidad así pasan las cosas tú
como muchas personas de tu edad y de tu
entorno no sólo debes aspirar sino estoy
seguro que puedes convertirte en una
influencia de verdadero en una persona
que tenga una influencia real en tu
nicho con tus amigos con tus contactos
con tus followers porque ante esas
personas verdaderamente puedes hacer un
cambio y si en este mundo con tantos
problemas hace algo falta son personas
que ante el odio respondan con amor que
antes
la desesperación respondan con esperanza
que ante la burla respondan con empatía
y si esa persona puede ser tú por qué no
serlo
porque los resultados pueden ser
terribles y por último y para cerrar
este ciclo con mucha claridad
recordarles que aunque todos tengamos
cosas malas que nos pasan todos los días
chiquitas y grandotas tienes una
decisión esas decisiones de la actitud
que tomas ante las cosas que te pone la
vida enfrente son lo que va a construir
tu felicidad y por extensión la de tu
mujer la de tus hijos
la de tus amigos la de tus empresas las
de tus negocios tú tienes esa decisión
la gente
que decide tomar decisiones
se llaman libres
las personas que no quieran tomar
decisiones se llama
atrás
[Aplausos]